das Narrenschiff ist Segel für fröhlich
weiter und zwar mit Volldampf über die
Berliner See an Bord zahlreiche
leichtmatrosinnen und zwar vorne weg die
Grünen Beispiele gibt es zu Hause die
Grünen die uns täglich mit Belehrungen
kommen über Veggie days und die absolute
Landwirtschaft sitzen fröhlich beim
Oktoberfest beieinander hingestalt von
Ricarda lang Claudia Roth und Katharina
Schulze Vorsicht drei Maßkrüge und eine
große schlachterplatte nach dem Motto
für uns das Fleisch für euch die Moral
das Energieunternehmen Juniper lässt uns
tagelang glauben dass die gasumlage
nicht kommt und dann muss er zugeben sie
kommt doch sonst fehlen 35 Milliarden
Euro irgendwie und die will auch nicht
Christian Lindner bezahlen aber warum
ist wirklich ist das kann er nicht
flüssig vertreten und auch erklären
stattdessen brüllt er die Opposition im
Bundestag mein Eindruck ist dass ein
Teil der Regierung komplett abgehoben
ist nach nur einem Jahr im Amt und
völlig den Boden unter den Füßen
verloren